[Music]
robocalls seem to plague nearly everyone
with a phone annoying right yep more
than 5 billion robo calls we agree on
that were made last month alone
lawmakers last week proposed bipartisan
legislation to find scam Robo callers up
to ten thousand dollars per call wow the
FCC is demanding telecommunications
companies lay out their plans to meet
the new standard so that the calls can
be identified and then stopped but as
Anna Werner shows us some companies are
better prepared than others and I can't
wait to hear a good morning to you good
morning yeah all we want is for those
calls to go away right yet it's
estimated that by early next year nearly
50% of all the calls you get on your
cell phone will be robo calls we asked
major companies what they're doing to
stop illegal robocallers and one
t-mobile offered to show us take you
behind the curtain here and you get to
see all the great technologies that we
have
t-mobile's programs to stop robo calls
begin in a lab packed with computer
servers this is where we test everything
that we
from that noisy room came t-mobile scam
ID program although the scammer is gonna
use a phone number that looks very close
to my phone number I'm still gonna know
that it's a scam it alerts customers to
problem calls they won't want to pick up
I knew the phone number I could see that
it was scam and I could send it away
company vice president grant castle
believes t-mobile is ahead of its
competitors and the Robo callers every
time we make an improvement the scammers
make a change and so it's it's an arms
race to see you know who can trick who
it's an art it's an arms race it is an
arms race it's escalating the scammers
are trying new technologies new ways to
scam people
so we're upping our technology to keep
up with them customers can use the scam
ID feature to screen unfamiliar calls or
block them completely and this week
t-mobile is launching a new app named ID
that will allow users to choose the type
of call they want to block everything
from nuisance calls to political or
charity calls even prison calls so with
this new app customers have better
control over what they would like to see
and what they don't want to see but the
FCC is also pushing companies to meet
new standards known by the acronym
shakin stirrer they would allow carriers
to verify calls with a digital
fingerprint to show that the person
making the call and the person receiving
the call are who they say they are not a
scammer trying to spoof or imitate a
phone number the standard is essentially
two operators have certificates or
tokens that they exchange with each
other in each call and more or less it
just says I am Who I am
t-mobile says it's ready and other major
carriers say they're working on it but
others apparently are not in letters the
FCC asked them why not and gave all 14
companies until today to detail their
plans to the agency as FCC Chairman a
Jeep I told us in March for those things
that are within our authority we're
pursuing them very aggressively
but in order for that plan to work all
carriers have to get on board and some
industry experts say even if that
happens scammers are gonna go where they
can find victims Aaron Foss founded
nomorobo for the limited time offer a
robo call blocking app for phones he
says those new shake and stir standards
are good up to a point what it doesn't
do is it doesn't say if that call is
legal it doesn't say anything about the
content it just says that you're that
number is allowed to be called so we'll
stop things like neighbor spoofing where
if you see it looks like it's coming
from somebody down the street but it's
absolutely not gonna solve the whole
robocco problem which is why Foss says
nomorobo takes an editorial approach to
robo calls blocking them entirely a lot
of the other competitors are labeling it
or saying things like spam likely scam
likely telemarketer we know that
consumers just don't want the phone to
even ring and that's what we're
delivering well nomorobo and t-mobile's
name ID app both have a small monthly
fee we reached out to all 14 phone
carriers that got that letter from the
FCC the majority responded and said they
will tell the FCC today what they are
preparing to do to adopt the new call
authentication system in 2019 whether
the carriers will be able to deploy that
system in 2019 remains to be seen
go grant council and t-mobile because I
think these guys are getting really
slick because they give my numbers a
nine one seven number so I get a little
on a nine eleven seven calls and I think
it must be somebody I know so what can
we do to stop it right now
and that's neighbor spoofing maybe
that's the greatest thing they like to
do which is it looks like a call to yes
somebody is
so some of the programs and apps will
now identify those calls t-mobile will
tell you what he said is that yes they
are going to be able to identify those
calls and they will know that it is a
spam call or a scam call and you can you
can download an app you can ask your
phone company what they are doing other
phone companies have some programs too
but some of them might still slip
through well I'm all for trying anything
if this is an arms race I'm ready to go
nuclear
it's so annoying I need to take your
number right Anna like if you have a 2
or 2 number then I'll get it - ok
frankly or not yeah her neighbor thank
you Anna works we'll update everybody on
this Tyrion